I want to learn how type people cook
their recipes I'm heading north
renowned for hot and aromatic dishes
it's the perfect place to learn to cook
Thailand's famous spicy food
Yuri yes hi how are you good to see you
my key to the north Huey
she runs a famous cookery school here
and she's the Oracle on this region's
dishes
so where we going now I'm taking you to
the house of the lady who make a very
good sausage is there not unties I said
this car fight wars agua yeah
mrs. rod has been selling a spicy
sausage from her doorstep for the past
20 years pleasure meeting you and these
are them yeah that's it Wow and this is
where she makes the sausages yeah the
legendary sausages I'd love to taste
them face pasty is it spicy sausage very
good very good indeed delicious she's
definitely the sausage Queen they're hot
they're as hot as a furnace but the
flavor is incredible I want to know mrs.
the rods secret when is she making the
next batch I would love for you to show
me how to make these she does not look
very happy
she was be danced with it or generally
she wants me to Dallas I've got a
devious heart well I'm a locker and
you're gonna sit in your country no I
wouldn't sell that sausage at home my
god no no no no I'd be shot if they're
that spicy deal mm-hmm yeah we're gonna
make a sausage let's go after our
intense negotiations mrs. Dodd reveals
her secret a grinder in a backyard where
she makes a spicy paste right where do
you start
I start up my dad's car she did she's
using hundreds of powerful Thai Chili's
she adds in shallots and garlic not
anything else and then to give it that
distinctive flavor she adds classic Thai
herbs so to Moritz given that really
nice vibrant color and that's the minced
pork that's all the ingredients ground
and mixed now for the tricky part okay
[Music]
it's fiddly work and misses rod thinks
that apprentice needs more practice